اعلن حزب الله اللبناني انه استهدف تجمعا
لجنود الاحتلال في محيط موقع الظهيره
واوقع فيه اصابات كما هجموا تجمعين اخرين
للجنود في محيط قلعه هنين وثك زرعيت من
جات افاد مراسل الجزيره بتعرض اطراف بلده
العديس الجنوبيه لبنان لغ غارتين
اسرائيليتين وقال ان المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
قصفت ايضا محيط بلدتي ارون وعيون وسهل
مرجعيون قال الدفاع المدني في جنوب لبنان
ان شخصين استشهدا في غاره اسرائيليه
استهدفت سياره في بلده البزوريه بمنطقه
صور جنوبي لبنان واشار مراسلنا الى ان
مسيره قصفت سياره لدى مرورها في بلده
البزوريه ما ادى الى احتراق السياره
بالكامل وقد عملت فرق الاسعاف على نقل
الضحايا الى
[موسيقى]
المستشفى ناحيته قال المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان الطائرات الحربيه نفذت
غارات على بنيه تحتيه وموقع استطلاع لحزب
الله في منطقه العديسه في جنوبي
لبنان من مرجعيون جنوب لبنان ينضم الينا
مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي ومن الجليل
الاعلى مراسله الجزيره جفاره البديري
ايهاب اذا مرجعيون من ضمن المناطق التي
استهدفت
ولكن ايضا اللافت وصول هذه الاستهدافات
الى صور ما الجديد
لديك نعم هذه المره الاولى التي يجري فيها
عمليه قصف بالمسيرات على هدف قرب مدينه
سور وبهذا القرب من هذه المدينه الحيويه
في جنوب لبنان وان كانت هذه المدينه تقع
ضمن عمل قوات الطوارئ الدوليه اليونيفل في
جنوب لبنان الا انها بعيده نسبيا عن
الحدود المعلومات تشير الى ان صاروخا
استهدف هذه السياره قرب بلده البازورية
التي تقوم برصد بعض السيارات التي تقوم
اما بتنفيذ عمليات او
تكون تقل مقاتلين او حتى فيها مسؤولين
لحزب الله سبق وان قامت المسيرات بقصف
ايضا سياره تابعه لكتائب القسام التابعه
لحماس في المنطقه القريبه من البازورية
ايضا المسيرات كانت استهدفت كذلك نائب
قائد وحده الرضوان وهي الوحده الرئيسيه في
حزب الله و بصاروخ حين كان يمر في منطقه
خربه سلم طبعا هذا جزء من سلسله طويله من
هذه الغارات التي تمت في جنوب لبنان طوال
الفتره الماضيه لكن الواضح في لبنان بان
التصعيد الاسرائيلي نرصد هذا التصعيد
والتصريحات الخاصه به مع جفارا البديري من
بديري من الجليل الاعلى
جفار على الاقل التصريحات السياسيه هي
الاكثر تصعيدا حتى من الميدان في هذه
الساعه هدوء نسبي ولكنه بالطبع حذر جدا
على طول خط الحدود ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي
كان قد اعلن في بيانه ظهر اليوم ان طائرات
حربيه اسرائيليه اغارت على موقع مراقبه
واستطلاع وبنى تحتيه ل حزب الله في منطقه
الا ديسه وايضا ان دبابه اسرائيليه هاجمت
احد المواقع قرب مزارع شبعه بعد اطلاق
قذائف منها ولكن كان اللافت صباح هذا
اليوم ان صفارات الانذار دوت ثلاث مرات من
بينها في زرعيت ولكن في المره الثانيه دوت
في اكثر من 16 موقعا وكان التشخيص ان هناك
تسلل لمسيره ليتضح في النهايه انه تشخيص
خاطئ وهذا ايضا ما حدث ليله امس عندما تم
الحديث ودوت صافرات الانذار في مدينه حيفا
كبرى المدن في الشمال واتضح ايضا انه لا
يوجد سوى صاروخ اعتراض لذلك دوت صافرات
الانذار ولكن على المستوى السياسي كما
ذكرت لك مياده هو التصعيد الاكبر بمعنى
انه نقل عن مصادر اسرائيليه رسميه ان
اسرائيل ارسلت رساله تحذير الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بانه ان لم يتم ابعاد
قوه الرضوان قوه النخب في حزب الله الى ما
بعد الليطاني فانه يجب على اسرائيل القيام
بالعمليه العسكريه الموسعه التي قد تصل
بالطبع الى الحرب على الجانب الاخر وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ايضا صعد من لهجته
عندما قال بان حزب الله خسر الحرب
التكتيكيه ولن يقبل طويلا بقاء السكان
النازحين من هنا على طول خط الحدود في
البلدات الشماليه بعيدين عن مواقعهم
وبالتالي يجب اعاده الامن والهدوء ان اضطر
ذلك الى نشوب الحرب مع لبنان شكرا جزيلا
لك اذا مراسله الجزيره جفار البديري
والشكر موصول لك ايهاب
العقدي